The following content is
provided under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help
MIT OpenCourseWare
continue to offer high quality
educational resources for free.
To make a donation or
view additional materials
from hundreds of MIT courses,
visit MIT OpenCourseWare
at ocw.mit.edu.
RUSS TEDRAKE: OK, so your
project presentations
we drew randomly last time.
Phillip, unfortunately,
got the short straw.
He's presenting today.
Don't feel too bad for him.
It's because he's going
to [INAUDIBLE] next week,
to ICRA, right?
So the plan is
eight minute talks
plus two minutes of
questions and transitions
between speakers.
You're free to use
your own laptop.
Hopefully it'll just
plug in and work.
You're also free to send
me slides so that I can--
I'll put on my laptop,
whichever is better for you.
If you have movies or something,
send them to me a few minutes
before so I can
make sure they play,
but whatever is better for you.
I'd like to ask you to try to
sort of-- in eight minutes--
I mean, it's
actually really hard
to give an eight
minute talk, right?
It's much easier to give
an hour and a half lecture.
You can just ramble on.
But you should try to sort of
efficiently cover the things
that I-- you know, the most
important things to say
are roughly, of course,
describing the problem you
chose, and it's always
good to say for a minute
why it's important
or it's interesting.
I'd like you to describe the
technical approach you took--
you chose, and why you chose it.
And then a quick
results, I mean,
as much as you can
get in, and if you
have any sort of interesting
implementation details
that came up, that reared
their heads, that's always fun
to say.
You're not going to be able to
fit much into eight minutes.
But tell us what
you've done so far.
And it's typically pretty fun.
You guys are not
going to believe
how cool the projects
you've all picked are.
It's going to be a lot of fun.
We did-- so we're in this
room Tuesday and Thursday.
I've asked them in the--
because there's a real chance
that we might run a little bit
over class, I asked
them if we could
try to keep the room
for the next hour.
They actually told
me that I could yet.
But hopefully we'll
be able to stay here
till 4:15 or something
if we need to to finish.
And the report-- I said it
before, but the report is--
is it working?
AUDIENCE: No, the
same thing has--
RUSS TEDRAKE: Why don't
you power it down.
That's when it worked last time.
Yeah.
It's due May 21st,
I said, right?
That's a Thursday.
So if you choose
the double column--
so I like to think of them
as ICRA format, for instance,
would be perfect.
That would be the
robotics conference.
But I'm not asking for a novel,
just a quick presentation
of what you did.
And I think you should
have the same points as
in the presentation,
but you'll have
a little bit more room to
tell about the implementation.
AUDIENCE: Is there a monetary
penalty for extra pages?
RUSS TEDRAKE: No, not at all.
That's right.
No publishing costs, and
you can use color figures
as much as you'd like.
Any other questions
about the project?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
RUSS TEDRAKE: I'm just
giving you a ballpark six
to eight pages.
If you come in at
five, I'm not going
to give you a huge
deduction if you say
everything you needed to say.
And you're free to--
it at least means
there's no publication
cost for extra pages, I guess.
And six to eight pages
double column in ICRA format
is more than six to eight
pages the other way.
So it's a rough guideline.
I'm just telling you,
you know, roughly--
AUDIENCE: So we can just
reformat it [INAUDIBLE]
six to eight pages?
RUSS TEDRAKE: That's
what I'm trying to avoid.
[LAUGHTER] Thank you.
I'm just trying to give you a
sense of the amount of content
that should be in there.
And you can format
it as you would like.
OK, excellent, so last
official lecture--
so I wanted to, as promised, end
my part of the class, at least,
on some success stories of
how all this stuff works
and has worked in the research
world over the last 15 years.
And so the ones I
picked out to talk
about were Emilio Frazzoli's
helicopter motion planning,
which--
so Emilio is upstairs in LIDS.
Some of the really primal--
some of the first good work
on learning in robots
was by Chris Atkeson.
And Stefan Schaal
was his student
at the time, who is now quite
established, obviously, at USC.
And then I'll tell you a little
bit about our perching project
depending on how much
time we have left, OK?
So let me start off
maybe with the lights
on telling you some of the
big ideas from Emilio's
planning for the helicopters.
This was actually
Emilio's thesis work.
And they've continued to use--
nobody here's from
Emilio's group, are they?
No.
Anybody know Emilio?
Yeah?
He's on your
committee, OK perfect.
That's good.
So this work already.
OK, correct me if I
say anything wrong.
OK, so the big challenge
that Emilio wanted
to address in his thesis was--
well, he does everything very,
very rigorously and formally.
So he's got many theoretical
contributions in his thesis.
But the experiment that
he wanted to get working
was we've got a helicopter,
let's say an RC class
helicopter.
And I want to drive
it from point A
to point B through potentially
a very cluttered environment
where the obstacles are
even moving in real time.
So he really wanted a real time
lightweight planning algorithm
that was as close to optimal
as possible in a minimum time
optimality sense but
that could run on
a-- you know, with 1 megabyte
of memory or something
on a computer that's on
board the helicopter.
And what he ended up doing
was a beautiful combination
of feedback control and
randomized motion planning.
And I want to tell you
some of those details.
OK, so the first
big idea in the--
if you talk to Emilio
about doing motion planning
and you say I've got some
nonlinear system f of x, u,
and I want to find a path
from start to the finish,
and I've got obstacles,
whatever, the standard motion
planning problem--
but these obstacles
could be moving--
the first thing he
would immediately say
and he has said to me is never
ever search over u's. That's
just seems like a
bad idea in general.
The [INAUDIBLE] that we talked
about, the naive implementation
is pick a point
at random and then
try to find the closest
point, and then find
the u which takes you as
close as possible to that.
He says, if you're
doing that, you're not
thinking about feedback
stabilization, for instance,
and you're working potentially
on a harder dynamical system
than you need to
be working with.
So he advocates first designing
a class of feedback policies.
Let's say it's-- they could be
time varying or time invariant,
right?
And they have maybe some--
they're parameterized,
for instance,
by some desired point.
And these feedback policies if--
ideally you generate
them carefully
and have some provable
stability guarantees about them.
And instead, then, of picking in
some u, which could potentially
be working on a system
that's very unstable, open
loop unstable, it might
require tight integration,
all these things.
Instead, you should sample over
the parameters of your feedback
policy.
So, for instance--
I'll make it more
specific in a second,
but for instance, if
I take a point here,
I find my closest
point on the map,
and I want to grow
towards it, instead
of trying a bunch of u's,
I say, what if I ran pi 1
with x desired of this?
How close-- x desired equals,
let's say, this point,
how close would it get me?
Or let's say I
run-- or maybe pi 10
would have been the closest one.
I'll pick the closest
feedback controller
that's parameterized
that's going to try
to get me close to that point.
OK, there's a lot of
benefits to doing that.
In a very real
way, it's talking--
we talked about feedback motion
planning as having advantages.
You know, if I--
I could come up with
a trajectory here
in the open loop sense that
if I went to stabilize,
it was not stabilizable.
This avoids that shortcoming
by actually searching
in the space of feedback laws.
And it also has
advantages, for instance,
that the dynamical system you're
simulating is probably stable.
So you could take larger
steps, integration steps.
You don't have to integrate
very carefully if you've
got a stable system.
So Emilio has advocated this
sort of trim and maneuver
view of the world
in motion planning,
especially on the helicopters.
So each of these feedback laws
that he considers at the motion
planning time are some
carefully designed controller.
They're of two types.
One of them is a
trim controller.
A trim controller for a
helicopter, for instance,
would be the hover, or
something that flies forward
with a steady speed, something
that banks with a steady speed.
All of these things
are trims where,
in the relative frame of the
helicopter, it's a fixed point.
All right, so-- and Emilio
was very careful in his work
to point out that you can
make heavy use of symmetries
and invariants in
those dynamics.
So, for instance, the horizontal
position of the helicopter
doesn't really matter.
If I know how to go forward from
x equals 0 in a trim condition,
then I also know how to
go forward from x equals 1
in a position, right?
If I know how to bank
at a certain speed,
I can do that from
any x location.
The location of the helicopter
doesn't affect that feedback
policy, OK?
All right, so if
you have a few--
what that allows you
to do, essentially,
is come up with a handful
of trim controllers
which do a lot of things.
In fact, what I think
he does in the end
is he comes up
with at around 10--
I think 25 was the number.
I remember-- I brought
his paper just in case.
Yeah, so he comes up with
25 trim trajectories, which
in his case was level
flight, no sideslip,
with forward velocities tiled
over, just to give you a sense
here, 0, 1.25, 2.5, 5, and
10 meters per second and then
angular heading
rates that are sort
of similar from negative 1,
negative 0.5, 0, 0.5, and 1
radians per second.
OK, so if he knows
how to do those 25
things, every
combination of those,
then he's got a pretty darn
good library of trim behaviors
that he can use as
possible controllers
that he could evaluate
on his system.
Now those are the
steady state behaviors.
And in order to
transition between trims
he does these
maneuvers, which are
finite time
stabilized transitions
between trim conditions.
And those maneuvers are
actually pretty cool.
I'll show you.
So some of them can be--
so, for instance, he
learned a maneuver that was the
transition from going forward
this way to being in the
opposite orientation going
forward this way.
And that maneuver-- I
shouldn't say learned--
he solved using a model
of the helicopter, right,
with dercall or something like
that, a trajectory that was
actually a snap roll, I think.
It kind of went up, and did this
thing, and then came back down
and went the other way.
And I'll show you a video that.
I had lunch with Emilio
and get his videos.
OK, so how does he design
the feedback controllers
for the trims?
He uses value iteration, right?
So we're current
and relevant, see?
So because he's got
actually a relatively low
dimensional space by
the time he exploits
these feedback invariants
and just worries
about the coordinates that
matter in these things,
he's actually able to tile the
space and run value iteration.
And the advantage of that,
of getting these trims,
is that he not only gets
the nominal controller,
but he gets the cost to
go from value iteration.
For the maneuvers,
he uses some sort
of back stepping optimization,
and he feedback stabilizes.
And he uses as an estimate of
the cost to go on the maneuvers
just the duration of the time.
Everything's a
minimum time problem.
So he uses the duration of
the trajectory as the cost
to go of these maneuvers.
And now when you go back
into the planning problem,
the search goes like this.
I pick a random point.
I start now asking every--
each of the existing
points in my graph--
let me give it an
initial graph here,
just to make it a little
bit more interesting.
I ask all of the
points on my graph
not if they're close
in the Euclidean sense,
but what's the
cost to go, what's
the value function of trying
to go from here to here.
Each of them will vote
on the cost to go.
And he takes-- he
starts-- he considers--
he tries to go in order
of the minimum cost
to the maximum cost.
Once he decides to try-- this
one has the lowest cost to go.
He actually tries to
expand that controller
in the direction
of here and checks
whether it's actually
feasible to running this pi 1
and with this x desired, whether
it can feasibly get here,
for instance, without-- if there
was an obstacle right here,
let's say, then it might be
that the motion plan is not
feasible to get
from there to there.
So he throws it out and
takes the next lowest cost.
And every time he
expands a node,
he'll pick the next lowest.
He'll search in these,
try all the policies
until he finds one
that's feasible
and tries to grow to there.
The result, actually, when
he puts it all together--
you should read the
papers, actually.
This is a-- it's
hard to do justice
in such a complicated
piece of work.
He's really-- he thinks of
everything, it feels like,
in his thesis.
The five minute presentation
here doesn't do it justice.
But he's got an
algorithm that works
fast enough that it
works in real time
even if the
obstacles are moving.
Because he's
computed-- the big idea
there is that you
used value iteration
to compute the cost to go for
the non-obstacle case, right?
You know how to
control the helicopter
when there's no obstacles.
And you use that as your
heuristic, your distance
metric, for the case where
you're planning with obstacles.
And it works fast
enough that he can be
flying his helicopter around--
he's got simulations of
like windows closing,
and it goes a different way.
Or the window's open, and he
goes through this minimum time
way.
And a lot of times
they still accomplish
finding a minimum
time trajectory from
start to the goal, even
with dynamic obstacles.
It's pretty good,
pretty good stuff.
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: So when you decide to
expand [INAUDIBLE] tree based
on the value iteration
result, and then you
simulate it in [INAUDIBLE]
came across an obstacle.
So the values there, is that
actually the q function,
or is it the v function?
RUSS TEDRAKE: It's a value
function, v function--
j.
AUDIENCE: OK, so
if that actually
happens to cross
an obstacle, there
might be another action getting
[INAUDIBLE] from that space.
And it wouldn't still
have the lowest cost.
But because the value iteration,
you'd just say the main--
[INAUDIBLE] another state
which has the lowest value.
RUSS TEDRAKE: It's true.
So he's careful to say that
when you go to this trims
and maneuver-- whenever
you're using feedback
controllers in here, one of the
things, you have to sacrifice,
actually, not only optimality,
but completeness, actually,
is that you can
only now be complete
if the solution lies in this
class of feedback policies.
So you're sort of--
he calls it pi complete
or something like this.
If there's a path from
the start to the goal that
is executed by these predesigned
feedback-- parameterized
feedback policies,
then you'll find it.
But you give up completeness.
And potentially
give up optimality.
Now, I would guess
that if it was--
there are cases where he
can try multiple things
and actually get around the
immediate problem you said.
But I'm sure-- I
would guess also
that there's cases
where he does say
I've just missed that solution.
So I'm sure there's some
things where you could try--
for instance, maybe pi 1
would have said it's feasible,
but there's an obstacle.
But then maybe if I ran pi 10
it would actually get me there.
Let me see what he gave me.
He gave-- so this is views
from his small helicopter.
AUDIENCE: Does--
this state space
has a velocity inside,
or [INAUDIBLE]??
RUSS TEDRAKE: The state space
absolutely has velocities.
It's very much about learning
a dynamic controller.
Some of these are invariants.
The obvious invariants are
in position and translation.
So the velocities maybe are not
one of the invariant-- maybe
they're supposedly
reasoned about.
But yes, it's very much a
[INAUDIBLE] dynamic planner.
So here's the on board.
This is sort of
the success story.
He's-- an on board video,
and you'll see a few of the--
I think this is the longer
version that we already had,
because you'll see some flips
and stuff in the middle.
So this is, I think, the--
no he called it a hammerhead.
I don't know all my
helicopter stunts.
This is the maneuver which
changed directions pretty
quickly, going back and around.
So they're doing pretty
aggressive things here
with, given the model, very
strong convergence guarantees.
OK, so especially
in these vehicles--
they're doing it now
with the forklift
to do inserting into a pallet,
and lift up pallets, and sort
of moving around
boxes and everything.
These real-time motion
planning strategies
based on clever implementations
of the RRTs, they're real.
They work.
And value iteration is
sort of real, and it works.
I asked Emilio what he
thought about the fact
that value iteration doesn't
solve the double integrator
rate.
And he was actually
very interested.
But it's sort of--
it's good enough.
For the purposes of this,
it wasn't-- it needn't be
a perfectly optimal controller,
just a coarse discretization,
solve it pretty fast.
That was good enough to give
you a working controller
with some stability
guarantees to use
in the rest of the
planning algorithms.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
RUSS TEDRAKE: It's just
dynamically replanning
all the time.
AUDIENCE: Did he have like all
the information [INAUDIBLE]??
RUSS TEDRAKE: So I think
that the strongest results
in the moving, I think, were
in a simulation environment
where it was fully known.
I don't know if--
I don't honestly know if
they had moving obstacles
in their physical demos.
That'd be cool.
OK, good, so evidence one that
these things really work, yeah?
I can't sort of talk about--
I can't do a whole class
talking about learning control
without mentioning Chris
and Stefan who are really
the guys that got
a lot of people
excited about these things.
So let me show you
some of their work.
Chris apparently also had
some helicopter stunts
that he did while he was at MIT.
And I haven't seen those videos.
But I hear they were
pretty good too.
So helicopters seem
to be a popular thing.
So this is a case of learning
sort of a cart pull problem.
This is a pole balancing task
with a big arm, a Sarcos arm.
The arm has actually
been sort of
mapped out with inverse
kinematics and inverse dynamics
control.
So really, he's moving the sled.
You can think of it almost
equivalently as a 2D cart--
and a pole that's not attached.
It's not a pin joint.
There's vision
coming off the side
with-- that's why there's
a bright pink ball
and a bright yellow ball.
So there's a vision
system watching,
doing the state estimation.
And they did a lot of work.
This was, really, some of the
first people that were making
real robots use these tools.
They were using cue
learning, value learning,
and they call it model-based
reinforcement learning.
Because they were trying
to distinguish between two
versions of the algorithm.
One was do system
identification on every trial.
Between trials,
solve your offline--
on that model, solve your
reinforcement learning problem.
And then put the
best controller back
on the robot versus doing the
trials exactly on the robot.
So this was their
model-based case.
And they argued heavily
that in these robots
it made a lot more
sense to use a model,
because even if the
model was designed
from a very few
trajectories, they
could learn a good
enough model of the robot
that the task would be
completed in just a few trials.
OK, so eight real
trials-- and that's
the only data they had
from the real robot.
They had some initial
guess at the parameters.
But then the system
identification
really happened each time.
They took the tennis ball off.
AUDIENCE: Is the range
of motion of the arm
limited, or is it just losing
control when the pole falls?
RUSS TEDRAKE: I think
it's losing control.
I think they're
trying to be safely
in the middle of the workspace.
OK, now the modeling,
the system identification
was only on the pole.
The arm was well known,
well characterized.
So they just learned a handful
of parameters for the pole.
But they did it in a few trials.
And then they showed
that the policy
could adjust that quickly.
And they became strong
advocates for model-based,
doing it offline.
Now, I would say that
in some of the problems
we've talked about in
class, for instance,
the fluid stuff that
Jon told you about,
that's a clear case--
I think, we think--
that learning the model
is not the shortest path
to getting success.
But on a robot arm, maybe it is.
They did that in a lot
of different cool tasks.
So they did, for
instance, double sticking.
They had a bunch
of different tasks
that worked with
sort of similar--
AUDIENCE: Is it using vision?
RUSS TEDRAKE: The
other ones were.
I would guess, since there's
no bright orange balls
and there is a stick,
that there's probably
some sensor on the other side.
But I don't know.
I don't remember, actually.
AUDIENCE: It's got
strings [INAUDIBLE]..
RUSS TEDRAKE: Yeah, I don't know
how they're doing the sensor.
AUDIENCE: I thought
that was just
to keep it from [INAUDIBLE].
RUSS TEDRAKE: From
wiping out, yeah,
from hitting the experimenter.
OK, so this was really a
cool time in robotics, right?
So the people, they're coming
in, and they're doing all--
making these robots do
things they hadn't done.
I'm sure cracking
a whip or something
was on the near horizon.
But interestingly--
so I have to tell you
that after a bunch of
experiments here and pushing
it and pushing it, I think
it's fair to say that Chris
and Stefan decided that
reinforcement learning
by itself was not the route
to super advanced robots.
And they switched to
working more heavily
on imitation learning,
which was still done
sort of in a reinforcement
learning context.
But they tried to
speed up learning
by getting trials from humans.
So there's a couple
of ways they did that.
First of all, they'd try to
learn the reward function
from the human.
Sometimes they'd try to
learn the dynamic model
from the human.
Sometimes they would try
to prime a value function
from a human, from
trials from a human.
They'd play all these
sort of-- at any place
in the reinforcement
learning framework
where you could expect to try
to use information from humans,
these are the kind of games
that people were playing
and continue to play.
The new helicopter results by
Pieter Abbeel and Andrew Ng
are really a success story
for imitation learning,
because they used
human pilots to drive
those initial trajectories.
So this is the pole
balancing with a human.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
RUSS TEDRAKE:
They're just watching
the dynamics of the pole, but
with a controller that works.
And they can use
that to sort of--
for instance, you could
just find the policy that--
[LAUGHTER]
That's Chris.
This is Auk, who was
just working with Stefan.
They were having DB play tennis,
and do drums, all these things.
[LAUGHTER]
Now, this particular example--
the other one obviously
was not-- but this
particular example
was more about
trajectory learning.
And they could
execute the trajectory
on a fully actuated robot.
But these are definitely
the success stories
in imitation learning.
AUDIENCE: He's no
terminator, for instance.
[LAUGHTER]
RUSS TEDRAKE: Oh, you
should see the new one.
[LAUGHTER]
Yeah, it doesn't have teeth.
But it could crush
through walls.
You know, it's this huge
hydraulic-- you've seen it,
Rick.
It's scary looking, right?
And the videos they
have, they're like--
AUDIENCE: They have one where
it's learning to kick box.
[LAUGHTER]
The researcher was a
kick boxer [INAUDIBLE]..
RUSS TEDRAKE: So that's the one
you've got to watch out for.
They're made by Sarcos,
all these big hydraulic--
I mean they're
powerful tethered--
serious power output robots.
Yeah, so the same--
back to the non-imitation,
but the learning.
Jun Morimoto working with Kenji
Doya and with Chris Atkeson
did things like
reinforcement learning
to make this little
robot stand up.
It's kind of cute.
I have to show it.
[LAUGHTER]
And then after a few trials
it would successfully
stand up, right?
And these are really-- these
are the cue learning kind
of algorithms I told you about.
So there's a lot of
good work out there
in that line of thinking.
Interestingly, I wanted to
show, to find the videos.
I couldn't find Jan's videos.
But I told you
Stefan and Chris had
started going towards imitation
learning and away from pure RL
in some ways.
But Stefan, I think, is back.
I don't know about Chris.
Chris is still on
the fence maybe.
But Stefan and Jan
Peters are the ones
that did this natural actor
critic algorithm which I just
wrote the reference on
the board on Tuesday.
And they-- now there's a new
wave of videos of a batting--
from a few years
ago, you know it's
playing tee ball or something.
It's hitting a bat to
try to hit a ball off.
And they've got a--
Jan's got a wham arm
doing a ball and cup
task like this, and maybe paddle
ball or these kind of tasks.
And it's the next
generation of these.
But it's without the
imitation learning.
It's the natural actor critic.
And they believe
that these algorithms
have gotten better enough
that it's interesting again.
OK, so that-- I mean,
that's actually--
I told you there's
[INAUDIBLE] that
run back and forth between
pegs to optimize their gaits.
There's a handful of stories
from robotics of these learning
algorithms working well.
There's a lot of success
stories of the motion planning
algorithms working well.
But they're sort of still not
quite mainstream robotics,
I'd say, the learning stuff.
If you really wanted to design
a controller, we'd still--
there's a handful
of people out there
that are still working on it.
But I obviously believe that's
one of the key ingredients
going forward.
So let me take a minute and
show you some of the stuff
that we've been doing in
a little bit more detail.
What you guys saw
yesterday still
has my yesterday data, yeah?
OK, so in our lab, we're--
I told you this in
snippets throughout.
But just to show
you really how we're
going at this today
in the research,
I really believe
that fluid dynamics
is a great domain where there's
tons of good control problems
to be solved.
And most of the problems
that are unsolved
are unsolved because
we don't have
good models that are useful
for designing controllers.
So this is, I think,
a particular domain
where I think the machine
learning algorithms
and the model-free
section of the course
is really going to help out.
You can do system
identification,
but you can also do
reinforcement learning to take
your best model-based controller
and improve it in a fluid,
for instance, setting where--
with just approximate models and
model-free control synthesis.
There's actually other places.
So Elena in our
group is now-- she
says she wants to do
plasmas or something.
So there are plenty
of other domains
where the dynamics are still
just ridiculously poorly
understood.
And you can imagine
if you wanted
to do control of some high
energy something or something
where the models
aren't good, there's
really not a lot of good
control work in those domains.
You could do some
of the first stuff.
So we've got two major fluid
projects in the lab right now.
One is the perching.
I showed you the video before.
I'll tell you the story now.
And I'll tell you a little bit
more about our robotic birds.
So perching is a
hard fluids problem.
Because if you go
to a high angle
of attack with your
airfoil then the flow
becomes very complicated.
It becomes nonlinear
and unsteady.
And linear control
and classical control
works well and in these
sort of low angle of attack
regimes on the left.
And that's what
fighter jets use today.
And when you go to the
high angle of attack,
the fighter jets
aren't doing bad.
We actually-- Rick was
just showing me today
he found the instruction
manual for doing
a Pugachev's Cobra, which
is this ridiculous task they
do in airshows.
And step one is like turn off
your flight control systems,
turn off all the warnings or
something like that, right?
[LAUGHTER] It's like, wow, OK.
But then it's just a
pretty rote maneuver.
You go through a
handful of trajectory--
controls.
And it does this sort of
nose up, nose back down.
So it's hard to say that that's
a high performance control
system just yet.
It's just sort of an loop thing
the pilots do in air shows.
Birds all the time are
doing beautifully complex
dynamic maneuvers.
My favorite now is when
they land on a perch,
because they go up to
incredibly high angle of attack
always in order to
actually generate
that complicated flow behind
the wing to generate more drag.
So when they get a--
when you get separation
on the back of your wing,
you get a pocket
of low pressure.
And you get a pressure drag,
that they sort of go up,
hit their wings out like this.
It's like hitting
the air brakes,
and they stop
dramatically faster.
So there's a handful of
projects out there doing this.
This is the Cornell
morphing plane project.
It's-- the idea in there is that
you actually morph your body up
to try to get a lot of drag.
But you keep your
wings morphed back down
so that they have
attached flow, and you can
do your linear control on that.
And then they move the
tail out of the way
so that the airflow on the
tail is again attached.
And they can do
standard linear control.
And John Howe does these prop
hang perching trajectories,
where he uses a lot of thrust to
stabilize his plane to go over
and sort of do a helicopter
kind of landing on the perch.
But these are sort
of not the approaches
that we would
advocate in the class.
This is-- my take on that
is that a lot of people
are trying to perch
by making planes that
work with old school control.
And I'd like to
advocate using our newer
tools to do nonlinear control
on more exciting vehicles,
let's say.
There's a couple of
military vehicles
that do these kind
of things too.
So Woody has been--
and the group
have been thinking
about how to make
a fair comparison
between the performance
of a bird and a plane.
And they point out that the
important variables here
are the mass, the wing area,
the density of the fluid.
If you're willing to sort of
characterize all these terms,
then you can come up with a
dimensionless quantity which
scores how effectively a
plane would land on a-- how
quickly a plane, for
instance, would decelerate
or a bird would decelerate
relative to what
you'd expect if you were a
flat plate and peak drag.
That's a fair way
to sort of back out
the stopping abilities of a
small bird versus a big plane
or something like this.
So it gives you a
dimensionless number.
Woody's not quite happy with us
calling it the perching number.
But I still call it
the perching number.
It means you're impressive if--
if you stop well, it's
impressive to be heavy, operate
in a low density fluid,
have a small wing area,
or stop in a short distance.
And now these numbers, you have
to take with a grain of salt,
because it's hard to get these
numbers out of the literature.
But our first crack at trying to
take these numbers from papers
and things like that--
a Boeing 747 not
trying to stop quickly,
this is trying to get you
safely to your destination, is--
if you look at as
it's decelerating,
just before it touches down,
it gets a number of 0.08.
So it's roughly using--
it's a very small fraction
of its available drag.
Because it's taking a
conservative approach.
Now the X31 was
trying to stop fast.
It's getting a perching number,
again, very roughly estimated,
of about 0.15 with sort of a 24
degree angle of attack landing.
The Cornell perching plane's
somewhere around 0.125.
That number we sort of
believe is accurate,
because we know the guys.
But they pointed out that
they were more worried
about, in their
perching trajectory,
not hitting the ground on
the way to the building.
So they optimized for something
other than perching number,
of course, too.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
from biology?
RUSS TEDRAKE: What's that?
Good.
So the birds are
more like this, yeah?
Now, that's using
a lot of thrust,
which we can penalize if we know
how to use metabolic-- measure
their metabolic cost.
And we're trying to get
numbers of it without thrust.
It's actually hard to get a
bird to land without flapping
its wings, right?
[LAUGHTER]
But we're actually working with
biologists at the field station
hopefully to get some
real numbers like that.
So what we'd love
to have is sort
of a plot of a length scale or
something over perching number
and show that it's invariant.
You know, the
small, small things
that fly like planes get
a bad perching number.
And big things
that fly like birds
get a small-- or a high perching
number and things like that.
And we're working on that.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
birds that naturally
land without flapping.
RUSS TEDRAKE: Are
there any birds?
So the case, I think, where
they land without flapping
is when they wind hover.
So it's not so much
about the bird as about
if there's enough
wind over the perch,
then they'll sometimes hover.
And then we could try to
find that kind of data.
And there are people that do--
so Rick had a
picture of a parrot
with-- a parakeet
with an oxygen mask
on trying to do energy
metabolics on a bird.
And, you know, everything's
possible, but--
AUDIENCE: There is an
s in the denominator.
That basically means like that
bigger planes [INAUDIBLE]??
RUSS TEDRAKE: Yes, so it's
impressive if you stop quickly
with a small wing.
Right?
AUDIENCE: But there is a
b zero and b f as well.
RUSS TEDRAKE: It's all
factored out in order
to be sort of-- so the initial
case, actually, was actually
m over rho s x, but that doesn't
handle the case where you don't
stop, go to zero speed.
So you actually need
this extra factor,
which is also
dimensionless in itself
to handle the case where you go
between some relative speeds.
I think it's-- yep?
AUDIENCE: Distance,
to me, [INAUDIBLE]
usually things that we make
are really bigger than birds
[INAUDIBLE].
RUSS TEDRAKE: That's why
we need to have a plot.
And we found that we have
a-- in our very sparse data
collection, we have
some inclination
that there are some
small planes that
have a worse perching
number than some big birds
and that it's actually--
we have successfully
taken out the dimensionality.
But this is work that we're
still trying to finish.
But just for fun, if you
wanted your Boeing 747
to get a perching
number of 11.7,
it means you'd have to
go from 450 mile an hour
cruise speed to
zero in 20 meters.
[LAUGHTER]
Right, so that's
pretty good, right?
OK, so why is it a
good control problem?
So this is all the reasons
that we've used in class.
But in these domains, the
fluid dynamics I think
are just prohibitively
complicated.
Their time varying
nonlinear, CFD simulations
are often very slow.
We're in a very--
we're around 10 to
the 5 Reynolds number
where CFD craps out.
And there's just not a lot of
good design accessible models.
Design accessible
means something
I could run any of my
control synthesis tools on.
AUDIENCE: Can the
wings of most planes
handle the kind of
drag that would be--
RUSS TEDRAKE: So
UAVs, I think, can.
But I think, yeah, I
mean, no question that
if we took-- even a
fighter jet, probably,
would rip its wings off.
But a 747 could not
physically stop in 20 meters
without ripping its
wings off, right?
So I'm not advocating
that we ride in planes
with perching numbers of this.
But UAVs, I think,
could do this--
small UAVs.
OK, so even if we did
have a perfect model,
it's still a hard problem
for all the reasons
we've talked about in class.
We have limited
control authority.
We have partial observability.
We didn't spend a
long time on that.
But if the dynamics of--
the state space, the
state of the fluid
matters when the things
are unsteady and nonlinear.
And we don't have
sensors for that.
The control forces
take time to develop.
So it's under-actuated
in that sense.
There's intermittent
control authority
from the stalling on the wings.
The control surfaces saturate.
There's a lot of good reasons
why it's still a hard control
problem.
You have to use the kind
of tools we work with.
So we did this
first by doing all
these model-based approaches.
We actually-- when we
started the project,
I didn't expect to have a
good model of the glider.
We thought this was immediately
a case where model-free
was going to be the solution.
But Rick's initial
data collection
started coming out
beautifully clean data.
And we tried to learn
an aerodynamic model
and started doing
model-based control.
So in this case,
it's actually maybe
what Chris and Stefan
would have called
as model-based reinforcement
learning, where
you learn a model and
then run the best policy.
It's in a motion capture
environment, these planes.
We-- Rick's built a
lot of foam planes.
Woody now has two.
So we've got a small foam plane.
It's got markers on here so that
the cameras offboard can sense
the position, orientation of
the plane relative to the perch
at about 119 Hertz.
The only thing onboard is that
servo motor you can just barely
see in the middle,
which is actuating
the elevator in the tail and
a battery and a receiver.
That's it.
Everything else is
offboard control.
You see that the wings are
bent up with some dihedral.
That gives it passive
role stability,
just the center of pressure
is above the center of mass.
And it's got a big tail.
So it's got sort
of yaw stability.
It's basically a dart.
It would never do
anything interesting out
of the plane, which is
the way they designed it.
But it's got perfectly
interesting and rich
longitudinal dynamics.
And that allows us
to simplify the model
to be sort of a planar
model, rigid body model
like we've been using a class.
In fact, in my notes when I
get back to posting the most
recent chapters, you'll
see our simple rigid body
model of the plane.
So Rick shot the
plane like 240 times
into the motion capture
environment with--
we basically flew into
the middle of the room,
then kicked its elevator
up, and then fell down,
or kicked its elevator
to a random place,
fell down, and
collected a lot of data.
We built a careful rigid
body vehicle model,
a careful model the equator.
We're making it
better and better.
Woody's got the next wave of
system identification now.
And you plot that
data over angle
of attack, the lift
and drag coefficients,
which are the standard
ways to do the system
identification in aircraft.
And the first thing
you'll notice here
is that it's data over
very large range of angles
of attack, which
is kind of cool,
because you don't get
that in real flight data
from real planes.
Because pilots don't do that.
It's the luxury of working with
foam planes and motion capture.
And the other cool thing is,
at least on our initial plane
designs, we've actually
broken it-- we built a plane
we thought was going
to be more ideal,
and we now have worse models.
But at least in
these initial planes,
we seem to have gotten
very, very good match
to some of the
textbook flat plate
models of quasi-steady flow.
Now, the drag coefficient
looks a little bit messier.
There's a-- it looks
like noise there.
But actually, we think
that's not noise.
We think if you watch a
time trajectory of this,
it's actually a
periodic oscillation,
which looks like the
vortex shedding of the--
it has the same
characteristic frequency
as the vortices we
see in the pictures
I'll show you in a minute.
OK, so we have a model where the
aerodynamics are fit from data.
The state space is 7,
roughly, sometimes 8,
depending on how we
model the actuator.
But that's just sort of--
I told you when we talked about
value iteration, I told you,
ah, you could do
it in 6 dimensions.
If you're crazy, you
could do it in 7.
So Rick's crazy, right?
And he did value
iteration on it first,
which I think is the
right thing to start with.
To find a cost function,
we said get to the perch
as close as you possibly can and
designed a nonlinear feedback
policy over the state space
that required discretizing
the entire big state
space very coarsely
and then doing some
optimized dynamic programming
on the cluster and
on all these things.
And he came back
with a policy which,
when we play it out could nicely
do these maneuvers, the post
stall, and we say
one out of five times
it would catch the perch.
Now those specifications
at the top there,
it's entering motion capture
at 6 meters per second.
The perch is 3 1/2 meters away.
Those are designed to try
to be a trajectory that you
could only acquire
the perch if you're
willing to go post stall.
You could only slow down fast
enough if you're post stall.
So these are the pictures.
We actually now have a
wind tunnel downstairs.
Rick, can I show everybody
your wind tunnel, Rick?
This is our wind
tunnel downstairs.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
RUSS TEDRAKE: Box fans--
so you have to-- so
my life changed when I
met Jun Zhang who works at NYU.
He's one of the best fluid
dynamicists you'll ever meet,
experimental fluid dynamicist.
And you go to his lab.
And he has box fans, and
like he takes pictures
with his digital camera.
And he's got, like-- it's the
most humble lab I've ever seen.
And he ends up
with fluid pictures
that are on the cover of
Science and you name it.
There's a real art
form to doing things,
I don't know if minimally, on
the cheap, something like that.
But we were very much
trying to do these sort of--
we're trying to channel Jun
a little bit with box fans
and you name it.
But we put the-- in that sort
of chamber, we emit smoke.
This is with still air,
before we put the box fans on.
You emit smoke from the
leading edge of the plane.
And you can watch
the vortices pull off
during a perching maneuver.
And we count those vortices.
And they're pretty
close alignment
to what we saw in
the [INAUDIBLE] data.
This is what-- this is a simpler
picture with a better fluid.
This is actually moving
the plane by hand.
But it had the vortices
with a lot less smoke.
And we were trying to--
tried to capture-- we're
trying to get quality like this
in pictures like this now.
AUDIENCE: Could you
just like burn something
at the front of the wing?
RUSS TEDRAKE: It's
titanium tetrachloride.
It reacts with the vapor
in the air and just--
yeah, and you don't want to
breathe it too much, right?
Rick says-- and you don't
want to leave it open
next to your wrench, right?
It corroded the wrench like
in an hour or something.
It was pretty scary.
[LAUGHTER]
OK, so how are we doing so far
in this dimensionless analysis?
We've got these planes
doing this much.
And our glider is
getting about a 0.55
in our current best estimates.
Again, the pigeon's
still whomping us.
So we're working on it.
So nowadays we're actually
trying to do LQR trees on it.
So the model-based approach
we're using is this,
is exactly what I
presented on the LQR trees.
In fact, we started
thinking about LQR trees
because we were trying to
figure out how to do a better--
the value iteration
felt like it was
wasting all of its resolution
in parts of the state space that
were completely irrelevant.
And the LQR trees were a
way to design trajectories
exactly in the relevant parts
of state space and nowhere else.
so that's where
that idea came from.
It's not working yet.
We've got a-- our model-based
LQR stabilization,
Woody's best thing is hitting
the perch about half the time
now.
But still, there's
sort of this--
the model-based-- when
the model's a little bit
off the real system,
we're still trying
to figure out how to handle the
differences between the model
and the real system.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE] perching
a real perch [INAUDIBLE]??
RUSS TEDRAKE: In
the simulator, we
can hit it from some
small initial conditions.
It depends on the model.
In Ricks' flat plate
model, it hits it
from a beautiful number
of initial conditions.
In sort of the more careful
system identification,
the problem is harder, because
the second derivatives are
larger, it seems.
So we're hitting it--
I mean, it still hits it
from the nominal trajectory
and hits it from a smaller
range of initial conditions.
But what we can't
do, for instance,
is take a simulated
trajectory and put it
into our model, which
is not quite a feasible
trajectory of the model.
It's close, but we
can't stabilize that.
We've got a big dynamical
system with lots
of interesting dynamics.
We've got one actuator.
And it's just-- it's hard
to make it do things.
So we're still
trying to figure out
if LQR trees are
the best way for it.
We'll see.
And Phillip's trying
to push LQR trees
on the compass [INAUDIBLE].
And Michael's trying
to do it on the dog.
OK, so now we're trying to do
it with flapping wings too.
So Rick's thesis is going to be
perching with flapping wings.
This is his simulation, which
I think looks like a Dragon.
[LAUGHTER]
So were those actually the
initial parameters of our bird,
or did you pick
them arbitrarily?
AUDIENCE: They're actually
closer to what the glider would
do if it was flapping.
RUSS TEDRAKE: Really?
Yeah.
So--
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
RUSS TEDRAKE: The time--
oh, because it's a whole second.
AUDIENCE: A 1-second trajectory
played over [INAUDIBLE]..
AUDIENCE: Oh, so it's
flapping [INAUDIBLE]..
RUSS TEDRAKE: Yeah.
AUDIENCE: It has the same
flapping frequency as the bird.
RUSS TEDRAKE: As the
ornithopter, yeah.
So this previous plot that
I went past quickly is--
basically says that
if you look at the--
if you do an LQR stabilization
of a perching trajectory, given
our original model, and you
look at the cost to go matrix,
and you look at the single--
I'm going to represent
that cost to go matrix
is the single costliest
direction of the s matrix going
backwards, yeah?
That's a quantifier
of how much error
you should expect to get if
you were to get a gust of wind,
let's say, in the worst possible
direction during your perch.
And it's a function of
time, because the s evolves
backwards.
So if you get a gust in the
worst possible direction
at your initial condition
in the model stabilized,
it can reject that nicely.
But in the last tenths of
a second, a gust of wind
is going to be very
hard to stabilize,
because you have limited
control authority, particularly
because your airspeed
is very small.
And therefore your
aerodynamic control authority
is very small.
And even if you put in
thrust or thrust vectoring,
it's still a big problem.
If your airspeed goes to 0, your
control authority goes to 0.
And that's one of the
reasons we think the flapping
is such a good idea.
That's one of the reasons we
think that the birds always
flap when they're
landing, because they're
trying to maintain air speed
on the control surfaces.
It's actually also a very
good way to decelerate.
So this is the big bird
upstairs in the lab.
You're welcome to come
see it any time, Zach,
who you remember coming in with
some robots at the beginning,
he's the one who built it.
He's an amazing designer.
He's also a welder.
This is a titanium welded
gearbox in the front.
It's a 300 watt outrunner motor.
He's designed in all the
failure points of the bird.
So when it inevitably crashes,
it's a breakaway beak.
The wing spars have
breakaway parts.
So you bring bucket
of parts out.
And this thing is--
it flew for the first
time last summer.
That's your TA
throwing it for you.
And it worked.
And then, oh my God, it's
going to hit the building!
So we turned it off, right?
But that was our first
successful flight
with an autonomous
ornithopter that
was stabilized just in pitch.
All right, so I'll
tell you quickly just
why we care about birds here.
And that'll be a
fun note to end on.
So basically, we care--
I care about birds not
so much about flapping,
but just about doing
all the great things
that birds can do
because I think
birds do fantastic things.
But you have to be a
little careful saying that.
Because if you look at speed
or efficiency sort of in still
air steady level
flight, then a propeller
is very, very efficient.
An airplane wing is
very highly optimized.
So you have to be
very careful trying
to say that birds are
going to be more efficient
or something than a plane
unless you go to the more
interesting flight regimes.
So birds are actually
incredibly efficient-- this
is in the notes.
An albatross can fly
for hours or days
without flapping
its wings just by--
even upwind-- just by exploiting
gradients in the sheer layer,
right?
So when the wind is
blowing, then there's
a lot more beautiful
things you can
do than a plane isn't doing.
So the cost of
transport of this guy,
the dimensionless
quantity, it's 0.1,
which is about the same as a
747 flying across the Atlantic,
which is cool.
But what's cooler is the fact
that the cost of transport
for this thing seems
to be the same when
it's sitting on the beach
versus flying across the ocean.
So it's basically
flying across the ocean
with almost no control energy.
It just locks its wings
in, uses the wind power,
and off it goes.
Butterflies go thousands of
kilometers carried by the wind.
Falcons can dive really fast.
The speed isn't the
impressive thing,
but the fact that they can
do super agile maneuvers
during these incredible dives,
like catching a sparrow out
of the air while it's
diving is really impressive.
Bats can catch prey
on their wings.
They've been studying down
at Brown, Kenny Breuer's lab,
they talk about
how these bats can
fly through thick rainforest
with 1,000 other bats
on their back, through
caves with stalactites
and stalagmites.
And they're doing all
these crazy things.
They've got a video of
this bat that can go--
he's going full speed this way.
And in five laps, or about--
actually, he said that he does
most of the turn in two flaps.
And they say in five
it's completely done.
In basically two flaps, he's
able to go full speed again
the other way.
And the whole maneuver takes
just under half a wingspan--
full speed this way,
full speed the other way
in half a wingspan, wow.
And the story goes,
and our mission
here in my robot
locomotion group upstairs
is to try to make machines
that can do this kind of stuff,
birds that are far surpassing
the performance of our best
engineered systems in a
lot of the performance
and efficiency, acceleration,
maneuverability,
but not in steady level
flight in still air,
but in the interesting
fluid cases.
And the trick is that
they're exploiting
unsteady aerodynamics.
They're doing control in
places where we're not
doing good control yet.
And it's a lot like, for
the robotics community,
I like to try to tell them
it's a manipulation problem.
If you're manipulating a
piece of chalk or something,
that's relatively easy.
You can see the chalk.
You know what your fingers
are supposed to do.
This is manipulating
vortices that you can't see.
You don't know what's coming.
It's a much nicer manipulation,
maybe the ultimate manipulation
problem.
And I like to say
that once you start
thinking of it as
manipulating vortices
and doing these sort
of clever things,
then suddenly you can see
why fixed wings aren't
as exciting anymore.
It's almost like
trying to pick up
a coffee cup with flippers on
or something like this, right?
So I don't actually care
about flapping per se.
And sometimes it matters.
But I care about having a
really delicate interaction
with the fluid.
And we're trying to
figure out how to do that.
So here's the-- did I show
this in the beginning?
Yeah, good, so you've
seen the dead fish.
So that's another example
of the efficient swimming.
And it's the story of our
pursuit of these controllers.
Awesome, OK, so I'm done.
Now it's your turn.
And we'll be-- let me
know if you have any more
questions about the projects.
We're going to pass
out evaluations
next week too through--
we have an online system
in EECS for evaluations.
I hope you give us
all the feedback.
And I hope you
enjoyed everything.
And I'll see you next week.